he's my little ducky car TV and offsets
little girl culture just turned one okay
the proud parents celebrated the
milestone birthday by sharing sweet
photos on Instagram she's so precious
Timothy cardi posting this shot of her
little one smashing a cupcake on her
mom's face alongside the caption a
little quick 12 o'clock turn up while
offset whose real name is tre shared
this adorable pic of their tiny tot
wearing a onesie reading 50% Kyary 50%
cardi 100% culture he captioned the
sweet shot quote you are so perfect love
you KK happy first v-day I love you more
of me you Noctis she loves me I love
them more about this she's just loyal to
whoever gives her the milk over the past
year fans have gotten to see a new side
to the 26 year old rapper as she took on
her new role as mama but nothing in this
world the Attic more than culture a
month before she turned one cardi posted
this pic of culture on Instagram writing
I'm madly overly in love with my child
if that weren't sweet enough
in September cardi snapped this sweet
mommy-daughter moment that's a photo of
her in culture touching hands alongside
the caption I needed a girl like you
and while culture was born in July she
didn't share the first photo of her
daughter until December with a caption
my heart I'm scared to share it to the
world you know I'm scared there's so
many people out there but sometimes I
just want to show people how beautiful
how precious she is you've nothing to be
scared about people are dying to see how
beautiful she is
I mean I know is there's a lot of people
that just have crazy minds you know want
to protect in March offset shared this
clip of cardi talking to their little
one kochu
removing the caption my beautiful baby
girl hashtag raising queens yeah that
cuteness was culture in May and it looks
like she might just be a mini cardi in
the making set caption the clip quote
culture remix I like it already platinum
so much character I love her down to
soul my naked
I like bordachev and cardi likes to
spoil her little girl rotten in may the
rapper reveals the bling she bought for
her then 10 month old the price tag a
whopping $80,000
she captioned the since deleted post
quote just spent a bag on my daughter
you know a bad [ __ ] gonna spoil her if
I my stout my daughter gotta be - and if
cardi flies private well so does culture
every single time that she'd get on the
airplane it's all good until the landing
she started crying and I just be feeling
so sad because it's like I know the pain
you know where your ears pop then
there's this picture perfect family
portrait cardi shared in April writing
happy Easter from mines to yours and
while she might be a mom now she's still
the same tell it like it is party after
giving birth to her baby girl she opened
up to et about the toll breastfeeding
had on her body I just got my boobs
redone did you really yes but this is
the axle yeah I'm feeling good
yes my daughter she did and she didn't
shy away from talking about that working
mom guilt sometimes I wake up in the
morning and I she's in my bed and I just
want to cuddle with totally is it
getting harder because she is growing up
and you're so busy and balancing
everything is it getting harder for you
it is getting harder because she knows
me like you know she recognizes more now
and it's just like you could just tell
that she like wants me there like
sometimes we should sing we leave is she
looking at this way boy
[Music]